m
ce jeudi 22 octobre 2015 la ccit base a
fêté son dixième anniversaire
seuls espaces publics numériques
accessibles et adaptés aux personnes
aveugles et malvoyants à la réunion la
ccit base par mr ce public de surfer sur
internet de lire le braille audio et de
découvrir des outils informatiques
adaptés un dispositif novateur porté par
le conseil départemental est intégré
dans ses services
alors là social est un espace public
numérique accessible adapté aux
personnes aveugles et malvoyantes
qui donc existe depuis dix ans à saint
pierre qui aujourd'hui est un sportif
unique en la réunion qui est destiné en
personnes aveugles et malvoyantes alors
en droit de la famille les
professionnels et j'ai envie au grand
public qui veut s'informer et à très
sensibilisée à la problématique de la
déficience ul
après c'est vrai que la principale
mission est maximale reste la
possibilité de l'année accès de faire
découvrir
les ordinateurs de clowns les couches
sociales
avec tact idée des personnes avec
l'accès aux technologies de
l'information et de la communication et
pour les déficients visuels un moyen de
communication complètement transparent
facilitant les échanges entre déficients
visuels et voyant moi je suis assez
souvent je viens une fois par semaine et
avec une autre copine à moi en fait on
soit enfin on se voit ici tous les
mercredis fait le bien qu'audi pour
communiquer c'est bien je vais dire pour
envoyer des messages des emails et tout
ça c'est bien d'eux d'avoir à deux mois
utiliser l'informatique
le département est un acteur essentiel
dans la politique en faveur des
personnes handicapées
c'est pour cela que la collectivité a
souhaité mettre en place ce service qui
apporte un mieux être pour les personnes
déficientes visuelles et favorise leur
insertion sociale et par service de la
collectivité
et je pense que souligner que le
département en la matière est un exemple
puisque
même au niveau national n'a pas que des
départs on peut effectivement de mettre
en place un tel service donc en faveur
des déficients visuels donc c est une
action innovante niveau pas collective
de la collectivité d'avoir voulu
effectivement installé dans sa structure
collective donc ce se servit de la
cécité
après 10 ans d'existence et un bilan
positif la stib a souhaité encore et
tout fait ces offres de services de
nombreuses perspectives de développement
sont prévues pour les prochaines années